I had to run and get my cookies and I
thre them over there and this woman she
got mad at me so I was going to leave
like I was leaving right now okay you
got your ID can I see your ID quick no
sir I don't got it but I got my
name give me one second let me write it
down just so it's easier if I write it
down are you able to like look up a
court date for me I can try cuz I'm
supposed to have a court date you are I
don't want to get a warn what for cuz I
had uh loading anding and I had um
battery
but um like a war battery or something
and I just got bailed out of jail give
me a favorite why don't you stand over
here so you're we're not in we're not in
the way of traffic okay I want to get
like a war okay give me a second let me
let me run you and then if you want to
chill I can look that up for you
okay me fa put your stuff
down yep you got you actually do have a
warrant what do you mean turn around
what do you mean you have a
warrant
R
stop you're under arrest
stop leave me
alone
Del the B stick fighting
wood
me look go my
Taser let go get off let
go get
off
yeah not now okay sorry please don't
first charges on me keep getting all the
charges don't move chares don't move do
not move was I going to get
released when was I going to get
released come on when was I going to get
released what was I going to get
released who's a vop warrant what is the
VP warrant final probation I'm sorry
come I
promise Char when will I get released
you releas when should I get have got
release
C pick up all female SE
[Music]
yeah okay
Brie you to take a
seat come on take a
seat I don't want to sit in the car know
what she got
good come on
keep her up
come I'm sorry okay please don't press
charges on
me please
don't the devil I'm
sorry I'm sorry okay it was the devil I
wanted to be a one I'll let you know all
that in a second but you got IDE when
could I get a got out when you probably
would have got out in the morning I'm
I'm sorry when Can Am I going to get
charges for years or you'll see the
judge in the morning okay
up ma'am do you want medical
attention okay we got fireing rout check
you out
okay
I want you to try to sit up lean up
against this back seat that's better
than I don't want you falling and hit
the
concrete grow
up stop touching
my bleeding I hear you I hear you I hear
you I
got
welcome
[Music]
back where is
he where is that Poli of
[Music]
I'm
sorry where is he it's so funny it's
funny
it's a seat your
it's I can't breathe you can't
breathe I can't
breath
okay se you a while
that arm from you yeah I'll take a look
at the
[Music]
picture canop
traic okay and I'll borrow
that Bravo just running up here I'm
pretty
sure
so you want
trans um we've got her in a car now uh
we'll
probably I mean if she's good we're
good 120 South rwood Florida Yankee 57
alpal Lima Romeo
and watch watch your leg
sweetie I was on top of her so started
over South to se grave they called they
told me she had a VP uh I think it was a
vop warrant I don't really remember it
right now I know it was a for
Warrant went to go
102 she runs down here turns around runs
up into SMA parking lot we come up the
hill I catch up to her right here at the
sidewalk push her up into the building
and she HS so I go on top of her trying
to secure her arms she balls up like a
fucking yeah Hedgehog and just starts
punching me in the in the head and
kicking me in the head and then where I
really start she tried to reach for my
Taser pull the mag mag out and um she
got the hood down on my
gun and
uh
all right sweti I'm have you hop on in
this nice little chair right here
okay no you're right here um I'm just
going to park my car real
quick she already inside